we don't have to tell you what the
makeup artist does just look at us
though often associated with monsters
and aliens and other creatures of the
bleak movie makeup is much more than all
that sometimes it's the creature even
more unlikely a man who grows younger as
he grows older and sometimes it's a
joker a joker who looks like the classic
Joker of batman lore but with a crazed
psychotic twist and sometimes well it is
a monster not just one but a whole
Golden Army open for makeup the nominees
are greg cannom for the Curious Case of
Benjamin Button John KAG Leone jr. and
Connor O'Sullivan for the Dark Knight
Mike elizalde and Tom flouts for Hellboy
2 the Golden Army the Oscar goes to the
curious cases appengine about me greg
cannom
thank you I want to thank the Academy
paramount Warner Brothers I share this
with Colleen Callahan who should be up
here with me I make up gene black Fiona
coach Elaine offers special make up
miles teves Brian Sipe will have Todd
Tucker Harvey lab remarked jaycation
Alexi O'Brien mark Nieman Chris Gallaher
art Martin Helen Cohen hair susan
Kalinowski and Natasha Fabian wigs are
fantastic director David Fincher see on
Chafin Kathleen Kennedy Frank Marshall
Sarah Spring Jim Davidson Bob Wagner
Daniel Stillman and of course Brad Pitt
Kate Blanchet taraji Henson
Jason Fleming Tilda Swinton tamale Jared
Harris and especially New Orleans thank
you